[Music]
in horny headaches news oh what a bummer
oh she I could do it yes submitted by a
nickel for a tickle a man suffers
extreme headaches every time he watches
online porn orgy that makes specifically
orgies overwhelming why does he keep
watching those then because it's just
temptation that's turned on by the
headache but you couldn't you don't have
to do orgies you could be like foursomes
or less what if that's like his [ __ ] but
I don't have to eat bacon but I still do
it there's turkey bacon that's still on
[ __ ] but they get headaches are reverse
I could have a heart attack you die at
any moment our reverse gangbangs
considered orgies what's a reverse pain
when it's all girls in one guy I feel
like this is still a gang bang grenade
what are they like women equality that
sounds it's just the same thing it's
just the opposite their gang bangs like
a guys with one girl in a reverse gang
bang is one guy with how do you reverse
gang bang a dude because he's not
getting [ __ ] in the ass yeah that's
what I see is the good getting pegged oh
so you need 10 girls with all with
strap-ons and then the bone it [ __ ]
the dude I consider reversed but yeah
that's a true reverse game pain but
that's not what it is
mm-hmm just just that's not fair why cuz
it's not a real game bang it's just no
but they're not that the guys are G but
that the guys not getting did in a booty
it's it's still pleasureful okay but in
a regular gangbang the guy gets the
pleasure so how do we get the pleasure
so we're all hopping on the resident I
didn't make the category [ __ ]
definition I if you type in reverse
gangbang that's what you'll witness and
they don't have strap ons on and and the
guys on do you girl on the balls what
are them
Oh so he still wins but that is but that
that is a category though where the
girls wear a strap-on and does the guy
in the booty hole yeah well I don't know
what
whole hmm why was I talking to get
headaches oh no that's what I see it so
the question is alright so is this an
orgy have to be like a dorm room guys
that's enough coffee because I've been
watching a lot lately where it's like
college [ __ ] Dornier dorm down cloudy
oh I don't even know that specific I
just go on walk through that door and
[ __ ] whatever's behind that that'd be
[ __ ] fine well that's not scary cuz
you don't find that door what if it's a
sheep I know isn't that fun that's like
scared or calm
what is this educational website this
education website is just college
students [ __ ] in orgies so I usually
find them more you know that's it's
actually a small group a Christian small
group college was never like that for me
anyways it was never like that I never
walked into the dorm all these girls
late
you know why Jarett or hide put that
[ __ ] on what are you talking about [ __ ]
magnet that's why that's why you didn't
get [ __ ] yes the Taiwanese scientists
recently Taiwanese scientist yes we
published their findings on this really
strange case study of this 40 year old
man who would only get headaches while
watching porn blood pressure that's why
[ __ ] is salty ass Chinese food song come
on now no it is specifically also the
orgy thing because that's what gets them
excited the most oh [ __ ] that's a lot of
just rushes to his head the other what
sort of his dick yeah yeah so he would
suffer from throbbing headaches and
watching porn
I don't think gaming reverse gang they
like Eastern European cuz they're all
pretty
no I just like when they put her on like
the like a butcher table what are you
all like that's like this to be and then
what actually is the same one I keep
watching you over who'd you like my
kebab yeah where they all like they I
don't know why they all like cream pie
her kind of sorry got a butcher table
hang on you're apologizing to a roomful
of people that want to hear more yeah
yeah yeah well basically it's just one
chick and there's this madam who escorts
ten men and it's basically a competition
to see like who can get her pregnant
like theoretically dude that's [ __ ]
hot yeah she's good look at David's feet
cuz she's like she's lying it headed
okay take I could [ __ ] take more
[ __ ] yeah and then she's saying
that she's like jab me pregnant it's
kind of empowering this [ __ ] question
when they cream pie her does that guy
the second kind puts his dick in the
spermicidal [ __ ] vaginal vagina I
hate that [ __ ] isn't that just like a
sperm cocktail then yeah cause he's
sperm sponsor and then if she were to
really get pregnant there's this thing
called mosaic baby oh we're like little
fragments of their DNA actually combined
to make like mosaics that's a real thing
holy [ __ ] so much my LeBron James and
Barbie a little bit of LeBron James we
didn't do it right
wait we should I got a basketball player
to come in and get some mosaics you had
three three guys to make your mosaics
include with Bart's a barbecue other
guys
Elon Musk it's one of mine yeah so weird
thing to relate to all right I want his
sperm to funny do someone artistic about
someone a flag oh [ __ ] what that's you
you know you know what he means by yeah
you you seem like Michael Phelps talked
about LeBron giant you gotta gotta think
of an artist you're right cuz you
already got this lettuce
then we have the science Elon Musk now
you have to someone really artsy yeah
you see Ross Wolfgang Puck well over
here this is her Bush this is your [ __ ]
I'll be back see I don't know that
Mister Rogers who are yours I think I
had me Bourdain he looks like he smells
like he's with idiot cigarettes
he's demeanor and I think that he's like
you know yeah okay
craft beer you know that guy yeah just
need a New York Italian guy yeah and I
had eaten Moscone and I had to take
Bobby because he would had his feelings
hurt he didn't exist
my third person that was fast all right
go ahead so I already have I don't know
I actually forgot we talked about this
on the podcast we're my picks killed how
you defi had an athlete [ __ ] like seven
guys yeah she surpassed three she was
just like seven or something why stop at
three you can have like a plenty things
to your mosaic but then you lose a point
that's my next vision board well there
was you who are your top three oh I
should have been thinking this whole
time I was trying to think of how to
tell you guys the story at least athlete
go I don't really know many athletes I
guess
oh just whatever is important to you so
you don't care what do you care about
like a traveler right you like traveling
people so maybe a traveling dude
a hobo you like small things maybe a
small dude no I don't like small things
and people it's just like little things
like things that you like and then which
guys embody those um I don't know
great the idea Casey Casey Casey her
looks I feel like immediately I'm
thinking Jason Momoa no that's a good
choice yeah
[Laughter]
just chasing do you want him as a
senator I think president well I just
has a horse dick right ya know cuz he's
strong okay so Jason Momoa Jason my boy
good one there we go those are my three
turkey baster to my hubby like Bill Nye
what Bill Nye what are you gonna regret
later have sex with oh you're just gonna
collect Casey come inside her with it
right just [ __ ] load up Casey's ball
sack with other people's syringe just
inject it yeah so you're only having sex
with your lover but you get their
qualities how about that other men's
sperm can we get animal sperm like I get
a rhino sperm injected into my balls
I've come that in her [ __ ] that [ __ ]
Rhino baby comes out with a [ __ ] horn
[Laughter]
I've even got a hole look at the [ __ ]
ultrasound that [ __ ] has a horn
on his face really good so do you guys
want to hear about this dude though yeah
well I guess you guys heard the good
chunk of the story which is the fact
that he gets headaches when he has
turned on they did find out though cuz
they they ran several tests he came out
think he was a perfectly normal guy like
he didn't have any weird sexual like
fetishes or anything like that his scans
his brain scans came out normal but they
did find though when they they did this
this certain type of test where they
used like a colored dropper and they
could see like where the activity in the
brain goes and so when he started
watching the
of his choice which was orgies they
found that the blood flow was faster on
the left side than his right side of the
face which was causing the pain but so
luckily after finding all this out they
were able to just treat him with her
meds no it's not Tylenol so what is it
he just needed more blood flow to the
right side of his brain to even it out
yeah pretty much
just break your vasodilate so you want
to be so constrict you want more blood
you want less the side that's getting a
lot of blood flows probably what's
causing the headache yeah they just they
just prescribed on the drugs it's kind
of complicated to say but yeah this drug
and and then like he just has to wait
about 15 minutes and then he can start
watching the porn I he like 15 that's so
much preparation because this doesn't
happen when he has sex with his wife
because he's a happily married you don't
want to have these oh yeah when a guy
jacks off like you know like a guy just
kind of like I got to do it you know if
we're a girl is it more like an event
not for me it's not no it can be 30
seconds yeah Wow
yeah anticlimactic live like for us that
he could be super eventful but it's like
[ __ ] man like I just I got [ __ ] to do
yeah yeah it's good morning
we don't have to make massagers
supergirls is more eventful than light
but today it's jackoff day you're lining
up the cab yeah you like our paddles in
[ __ ] you open up your novel and then you
just go but you know because we're a guy
is just so like just RK yeah we're
crusty we are like food in one hand it's
it's no different huh
I also used the bristle n of a
toothbrush to masturbate so who knows
I'm sorry
bristle it was like that because there's
plenty of videos of girls online doing
that job what toothpaste on it I'm not
brushing my vagina
I'm never petting your dog I'm not going
into your bathrobe i eating a sandwich
from you or nothing dude you're going on
a house she opens a door Jack the dog oh
[ __ ] is going on in this house you can
pet her dogs just don't [ __ ] let her
pet your dog huh your dog is so cute
that's [ __ ] funny get the [ __ ] away
when you're a teenager you have to get
creative and you have to find [ __ ] that
vibrate how come you just get what we
don't a guy's gonna [ __ ] there but I
don't know right my mom had this brush I
don't know why me she probably it
monster hey I got your back you know why
because in college that was one of my
favorite that was one of my favorite
searching here girls masturbating with
hairbrush wait what yeah
serious because it was goofy you know
why it's good you're gonna see you use
the brush and I'm like friends why would
I use a brush to [ __ ] myself way like
that why is that not bad no I'm just
saying it's the cool thing because no
look no I'm not watching you you weirdo
that's like going okay let me let me let
me all you go that [ __ ] masturbate
with a brush or a comb or anything you
guys like the bleeding your vagina use a
comb you know why because it's different
from [ __ ] like well-produced porn
well-produced point is like your [ __ ]
fake right oh yeah if they're the same
age as me like a college-age girl that's
[ __ ] masturbating with a [ __ ]
hairbrush wait we never even heard your
story though what happened with the and
get what you think uh no cuz I I mean I
was I was a young ass kid I don't have a
credit card to buy should discreetly
online I didn't have the freedom to go
to [ __ ] what is it a toy store
whatever to get whatever I wanted I got
creative with whatever I could which I
did the [ __ ] water faucet with what
is it the thing that was bomb because it
was free um and then my mom had like
this bright like she just had it in her
drawer and then I'm like oh what is this
antique oh [ __ ] and there's a horny
[ __ ] kid you're trying to just find
anything so I'm like this is tight so
then I borrowed it my mom's I could
happen to my brush I'm like I don't know
where'd you put your [ __ ] why does your
mom have a vibrating brush
she probably use it for the same thing
now that I'm thinking about like what
would they invent some really your hair
follicle follicle no I did I bet you
anything people made that so older women
could [ __ ] masturbate
a Bayesian game big rehearsal but
bristle like the hairs I know what is so
weird about that cuz you know my brushes
have a heritage I didn't put it inside
me you weirdo is just for clitoral
stimulation that caused inside me is a
[ __ ] big fat [ __ ] look at me like
I'm a weirdo you [ __ ] weirdo I don't
do that I just let it airs give it back
to my mother
[Laughter]
[Music]